Hausa compresses beautiful today when it
pleased him work with meat motion
alright okay yeah but even benefit that
science was not made for this don't what
well I know where that hand has been
don't shake hands to negotiate hey I
guess we'll shake [__] hands whatever
is it looking I feel very uncomfortable
with this
okay we're shaking hands pull back your
hand to renegotiate what I'm one of what
is this what am I gonna
My dear [__] boy I consent to wreck
your ass yes
meet my get on your goddamn knees hurt
me plenty my queen
God flick your wrist to discipline [__]
boy
what the [__]
safe word it wants me to stop too much
for you but I sorry this [__] himself
sorry let's see I have a reputation oh
my god hey buddy hey buddy
don't be sad I'm sorry I went a little
hard on you buddy hey come on now
Jeffrey don't be exotic it's gonna be
okay hey how about round number two I
feel so dirty playing this game so very
very dirty you went too rough back there
yeah come on Jerry you know I like you
know you like it rough
I said myspace safe word you're really
dangerous and scary step away from me
hey come on Jerry that's what let's just
let's just try again or I just put some
ointment on there I have to wait a day
damn it alright well I'll be back I'll
be [__] back oh my god just oh my god
next game Ferrari cops
really all right then in Ferrari carpet
is [__] ends people snatch as I don't
[__] know
get off me car literally I wanna - let's
video games a science gone too far I
don't think so
alright quality
probably the gameplay quality gameplay
best game ever Tara how mad handsome
whoa oh yeah BJ oh yeah why are my hands
hammers who gave me this cruel fate this
is not as awesome as I and hope for
stupid cutlery appearing in front of me
why why am I doomed to this face hi my
favorite game neon hairdresser on oh I
love it
oh god my head whoopsie oops oh my god
I'm so sorry
such lovely hair alright let's cut it
all off
and sell later Wharf ins and then wait
what give it to orphans I I don't know
this is so creepy what the [__] am i
doing there you go much better you look
fabulous
it was a good monster here give me kill
me
can't here let me to kill you let me -
Kelly is so cute it's so cute you show
your bitch-ass mortar [__] [__] ass
sorry I'm so sorry I get to chose a song
okay I'll go with Spice Girls please
what the [__] is happening well I'm I'm
a tentacle this is great oh my god I'm
great flaying with us today I hope you
had a lot of fun if you did leave it
like it subscribe covered today and as
always stay awesome